thank you guys so much for sitting down
with us I love the movie I gotta say
first of all I made the mistake of going
in with the empty stomach watching it
just all the food I just thought it was
like torture oh right after I ate a
bunch but I was just curious Ally so can
you talk about transitioning from doing
the stand-ups on Netflix and and
creating an original movie was our
process like the relationship with them
I mean it's just so nice because it's
it's really collaborative stand-up
you're just like a what do you call it a
lone wolf a ninja what do you call it a
Sam what do you call it was like it's a
samurai who's on their own yeah like
that you know you get it so cuz you know
like I write all material by myself I
decide how I'm gonna move how I'm gonna
speak all by myself and this was like
making a project with two people who I
loved respected my who have known for a
long time it was just so easy and
organic and fun and uh and I just felt
so supported you know but the film is
definitely you know there's a lot more
vulnerable moments that I think will be
interesting there was certainly
interesting for me to play and yeah I
really enjoyed it
yeah I'm not I'm not a super rock on God
but I think by the end of movie I was
like wait is this it and Randle with you
when are we get him the mixtape like oh
my god that's not coming out but it was
music a passion for yours not just
something for the the script and a story
or what if it was like I hate music
music terrible music brings me down and
the ban is based on a real band that I
was in way back in the day open and and
it was kind of like well what if that
band kept going well and so our
adulthoods
there's a great band I wish they were
still together the one in real life and
the one in the movie but the one in real
life is almost even better yeah I mean
it was
I don't know about that but idea so this
is kind of like based off of you guys is
live like a little bit of inspired by
your life like the band for example
stuff like that you kind of pull with
that into this movie or was just more
like yeah those aspects I think people
who know us will probably be able to see
more things yeah
then we've even been able to track yeah
but yeah I mean that's certainly a
direct part of his past I think that the
character that he plays is like a big
part of my past like I dated so many
Marcus's you know and and I love that
guy and I've been I'm dying to have that
guy on see that guy and put that guy on
camera a guy who's passionate about his
art and still lives at home and has a
day job and you know doesn't is just
like so complacent and happy you know
and I and I've always been drawn to
those guys and I love those guys and and
when you see them on camera and movies
in TV there's social abhi and cartoony
and they're like borderline homeless but
really this is it's so refreshing to me
to see grounded version of that guy who
who essentially has it all you know yeah
I feel you ain't like that cuz I was
kind of relating to that character well
he's desired to you know it's not like
this woman's like trying to get away
from like she she tells him that she
loves him she wants to beat them but he
can't handle it can you guys something
how did the idea for bringing Keanu
Reeves in how did that even come up or
what was that like uh well we thought
about you know at that story point like
when Marcus finally decides to tell
Sasha like I have feelings for you we
thought okay Sasha is dating someone who
would be Marcus's worst nightmare and we
knew we wanted an Asian American icon
who was great actor who could also be
funny and the only person who fits all
those parameters is Keanu Reeves so he
was always our first choice there was no
way we were gonna get him there was just
no way so we were like okay we got to
come up with some some options but we we
went out to him and he just got it and
we still can't believe it
I mean and now okay so John would for us
we've been confirmed you guys got to
reach back up it's been confirmed that's
been come oh wow got to reach on
like hey we gave you shadow John we got
a shout-out can we get a did you see him
in John wick Joe when Commons shows up
and you're like Microsoft commercial
anyways and I just graduate from college
recently and I just wanted to know you
guys can you guys talk about on your
experience like just give me advice for
aspiring actors or writers trying to
pursue their career and trying to make
it out here in this industry like advice
you would give to them I'm failure you
know and just not trying to avoid it and
or and just expecting it to be part of
the process
you know and over I just like on I found
this old picture of the sketch group
that I was in that I completely forgot
about from 2007 and I was like oh yeah
that was something that I did that
ultimately never led anything led to
anything but it is true that you know
your failures don't add up so if you're
passionate about something and if you
truly believe that you're good at it and
if you're in touch with reality and you
are good at it you should keep going and
you can't go wrong yeah thank you for
that so let's play I just want to play a
quick game of would you rather with is
that all right with you guys
all right so would you rather have your
childhood question make their feelings
way too late or just be left wondering
for ever admit their feeling omid their
feelings I think so yeah all right would
you rather be asked to cry on cue or
sneeze on cue sneeze on cue sneeze on
cue yeah all right would you rather do a
scene running the entire time or eating
the entire time running yeah eating gets
torturous after a while we did a lot of
that in the room that beef in the
restaurant scene killed me
I'd say eating I'd say eating cuz I
don't like to run alright would you
rather mess up a bunch of takes or have
somebody mess up your best take I don't
like to mess up takes like I try to you
know keep it moving but I probably say
someone mess up my best
what about I'd rather mess up a buncha
takes yeah would you rather work with a
director that gives too many notes or
not enough not enough I think but when
they do they're like rude not annoying
like that's that's the ninotchka
that's our director Sheila when she
gives a note it's a good note usually
yeah yeah I would say I would actually
say too many notes well no I would say
not enough no too many okay then you can
choose yeah that's true yeah all right
well thank you guys so much so yeah I
love the movie I can't wait for people
to see